[Music]
so you want to go to Stanford yes I
almost got a perfect score on my SATs
you're a good student but Sierra
what's your self excuse me Sierra
Burgess is funny kid wonder
you are a magnificent Beast I feel
sometimes I give the one teenager who
German obsessive who looks oh sorry dude
I wonder what life is like rejects
Veronica Frodo is from Lord of the Rings
you're thinking of Quasimodo The
Hunchback of Notre nom and then looking
at you makes me want to gouge my eyes
out how many guys we texted he
definitely thinks that I'm something
else
it's called catfish and I'm pretty sure
it's illegal oh my god oh that's what I
have to live up to all the phone numbers
in the world he texted mine you need to
tell him the truth they're my words he's
falling for me are you more than just a
hot jock how you thinking no would you
want to go on a date with me yeah I know
you've been feeling all your classes so
so I think we can help each other I do
need a favor
are you sure this is gonna work no oh my
gosh good answer hey hey
so how was your day you know what audios
not since the video that get off maybe
we should try again another time you
know the hardest part is allowing
yourself to people
[Music]
the truth
even though you animal
wait your worst not that bad she's
actually kind of cool terrifying I know
what I am
[Music]
[Music]